[Aplausos]
[Música]
muito boa noite
hoje eu vim falar de um assunto que todo
mundo conhece ou pelo menos
acha que conhece a violência doméstica
depois que eu terminar a minha fala mais
de 150 mulheres vão ter sofrido agressão
aqui no brasil segundo o datafolha de
todo mundo sabe que isso acontece
o que a gente não sabe é como isso
acontece
bom quem sou eu pra tá falando disso meu
nome é dora figueiredo eu tenho 25 anos
como falaram eu tenho um canal no
youtube fala sobre o empoderamento
feminino também fala sobre
relacionamentos de uma maneira muito
leve
é eu tenho uma mãe maravilhosa que me
ensinou a ser uma mulher independente
cresci e nasci numa família é muito boa
maravilhosa em são paulo é e nada disso
nenhuma dessas coisas me impediu de
sofrer violência doméstica
eu vivia um relacionamento onde eu tinha
medo de deixar o cargo foi a faca
desalinhada depois da refeição porque
ele controlava o jeito que eu comia eu
entrei anorexia porque ele controlava o
meu peso e eu cheguei a achar que
apanhar dentro do sexo por mais que eu
não gostasse era o certo a se fazer
porque ele precisava se desestressar do
trabalho
eu sofria as sessões de tortura
psicológica que duravam quase duas horas
e ele só terminava quando eu tinha uma
crise de ansiedade não conseguia mais me
mexer
você deve estar pensando como que ela
adora figueiredo deixou isso acontecer
eu também já pensa isso várias vezes me
sentia muito burra inclusive
mas aí quando a gente sai a gente
percebe a culpa nunca da vítima e que se
eu adora figueiredo com toda a criação
que eu tive e com todo a informação que
eu tive
passei por isso é porque a violência
doméstica é muito mais difícil de ser
evitada do que a gente imagina
bom eu passei em algum nível todos os
tipos de violência que a lei maria da
penha abrange a violência moral
psicológica a patrimonial sexual ea
física
vamos começar pela moral e psicológica
dentro do meu relacionamento a pessoa
que dizia me amarro falava que eu era a
pessoa mais fraca que ele já tinha
conhecido a vida que tava procurando
outras mulheres que não tivessem o tempo
todo doente porque estava com depressão
e que ele não imaginava nunca que eu
jamais iria superar a depressão como eu
falei eu sofria torturas psicológicas
bem graves
ele começava a brigar comigo por um
motivo e no meio da briga ele criava
tantos outros motivos para dizer que eu
estava errada e que eu era louca que eu
realmente quero chegar a acreditar que
eu estava louca
isso chama gaslight eu ficava tão mal
mas tão mal que eu chegava a ter uma
crise de ansiedade pra quem sabe uma
crise de ansiedade é um desespero você
não sabe o que você faz você vai se
dobrando cada vez mais e aí vai ficar em
recuperação em relação à sua recuperação
chega um momento que você acha que vai
morrer
era nesse momento ele parava
tá mas não ele não parava porque ele é
que sentia mal com que ele tinha feito
ele se ele parava porque ele falava olha
isso por isso que eu não gosto de
conversar com você porque eu não falo
com você porque não é qualquer coisa que
eu faço você entra nesse estado
ele parava tá aí ó tentando né às vezes
explicar para ele então talvez isso aqui
seja uma violência eu conversei com um
amigo
o bom quando eu falei que eu conversei
com um amigo foi o que eu ouvi abre
aspas
dora não adianta você conversar com
ninguém
foi tudo certo para o gol mas vai ficar
tudo certo aí a abre aspas abre aspas
dora não adianta você conversar com
ninguém porque eu sou um ser humano
muito evoluído uma alma muito antiga
tá uma alma muito antiga abre aspas
eu sou um ser humano muito evoluído uma
alma muito antiga
tá uma alma muito antiga
então não adianta falar nada pra ninguém
que ninguém vai entender
tá então tá bom vou fazer o que é bom
a violência moral ele enquanto não podia
falar nada do nosso relacionamento com
as outras pessoas ele falava que eu era
louca que eu era ciumenta chegou a falar
com a minha mãe mãe é essa que eu fiquei
meses sem falar que eu tinha medo de
falar do nosso relacionamento bom
depois é a violência patrimonial que eu
acho que foi uma das mais sutis
é assim a gente tinha uma vida de luxo
eu tinha muitos anos a menos que ele
segundo ele era milionário e eu estava
começando a minha carreira e ele falou
que a gente tinha que ter aquela vida de
luxo porque tinha que teve de julho eu
falava não dá pra ficar um pouquinho
mais perto do metrô ou sei lá comer no
restaurante um pouco mais barato e ele
virava para mim e falava
agora se você quer viver com sua mãe é
só você voltar você quer ficar comigo
essa é a vida que eu voltei eu falava tá
bom vou lá estava todo meu dinheiro aí
surpreendentemente eu economizei uma
graninha e aí quando eu tinha na
graninha ele virou pra mim e falou assim
dói eu acho um absurdo você ter dinheiro
guardado porque eu sou um homem rico
2 porque a sua mãe tem uma dívida e eu
acho injusto você ter dinheiro com a sua
mãe tem uma dívida
eu falei está a calma não sei
mas esse é o meu dinheiro para os
próximos meses não têm como pagar o
aluguel nos próximos meses ele não
relaxa
eu sou um homem incrível rico e eu tô
aqui pra qualquer coisa eu falei nossa
será agora ele entendeu que é um
relacionamento gente felicidade
bom não no próximo mês eu precisava de
dinheiro para pagar aluguel e eu não
tinha e aí ele começou a me olhar e
falar bom dora viu que adianta você tem
algum sucesso na sua carreira
se você não tem dinheiro pra pagar
aluguel nesse momento ele já tinha uma
dependência emocional porque não sabia
mais quem eu era e ele já tinha agora a
minha dependência financeira dá um bom a
gente vai pra violência sexual e física
que é a parte mais difícil né aqui pra
todo mundo
eu estava completamente cega
eu não sabia o que estava acontecendo eu
nem imaginava que aquilo era um
relacionamento abusivo e durante o sexo
ele espancava
ele me batia até o chorar mas eu tinha
que chorar escondido porque se ele
percebesse que eu estava chorando ele
ficava bravo ele não ficava nossa meu
deus tá chorando que eu posso fazer por
não ficar bravo está muito bravo e
ficava semana sem tocar em mim mesmo que
eu pedisse ele chegou a mostrar a foto
das ex namoradas dele roxa todos roxos e
falou assim quando você for a minha você
vai deixar de bater desse jeito eu não
queria que ele me deixasse bater eu não
queria deixar ele bater daquele jeito
mais ele é a única coisa que eu tinha um
amigo ele a faz todo mundo é não tinha
mas minha mãe estava longe
eu não sabia mais o que era real que era
real se eu era louca ele é louco que
estava acontecendo na minha vida então
eu deixei
afinal ele era única pessoa da minha
vida
ele é o amor da minha vida
bom é sanção
algumas formas de violência que eu
passei
porém é não precisa ser assim na
violência moral ele pode falar alguma
coisa pra sua família que na verdade na
psicológica ele pode chamar de burra
feia inútil na patrimonial ele pode
falar para você parar de trabalhar ou
pode pegar o celular sabe viu aquilo que
não queria ver e taka na parede à
violência patrimonial encaixa na lei
maria da penha também pode reverenciar
sexual a gente acha que é só o estupro
que isto existe dentro do casamento da e
do relacionamento mas ele pode também
falar pra você fazer um aborto ou falar
que você tem que ir ou não tem que usar
pílula anticoncepcional que afinal o
direito sexual é seu da mulher ea
violência física é que todo mundo
conhece a gente não precisa esperar até
a 5 a chamar a polícia
qualquer uma delas já enquadra na lei
maria da penha
eu num não percebi eu só percebi dois
meses depois que o relacionamento tinha
acabado
bom como isso acontece né como que a
gente mas que deixa acontecer mas a
realidade é só a gente parar e olhar
para a vida da mulher como agente quais
são os nossos referenciais das princesas
eu queria ser uma princesa eu queria ter
um marido
eu queria saber querer saber que nem
final de novela
casou teve filhos acabou feliz para
sempre
eu queria isso para mim era tudo que
estou buscando
hoje eu vejo que a submissão feminina é
uma coisa que foi inventada com o tempo
e que não é natural
segundo o antropólogo rios henry morgan
é nasceu o livro a sociedade antiga ele
mostra que as mulheres já foram deusas
eu em momento algum me senti deus dentro
do relacionamento ou nenhuma mãe da
minha vida é ele falou as mulheres eram
deuses e aí quando os homens foram
conseguindo ganhar bem
com as guerras e juntando esse capital e
perceberam que eles tinham alguma coisa
a ver com a reprodução não sabe onde tem
gente não tinha exame de dna
aí eles foram bom agora é preciso passar
esse dinheiro para esse dinheiro se bem
para os meus filhos homens claro
então eles impuseram a monogamia
bom a mulher de uso se tornou
propriedade foi vendo tudo isso que eu
fui percebendo que aos poucos a ilusão
de que tem um homem do meu lado foi o
suficiente foi se esvaziando mas mesmo
assim eu estava naquele lugar né
mas não foi a ilusão de que tem um homem
do meu lado que me segurou a mim o que
me segurou ali foi o que a psicóloga
maravilhosa
leandro é de walker chamou de um ciclo
do abuso google brasil é então a gente
vive num momento de tensão a gente que
passa por violência doméstica então
qualquer coisa por que motivo é motivo
para a humilhação para a provocação
ofensa você é burra deixa que eu faço
aí ela vai lá e faz uma coisa errada bom
aí a gente vai pra explosão pode rolar
tapa pode rolar violência física pode
votar pode acontecer violência sexual ou
também ele pode fazer passar mal de
ansiedade que nem o meu e se fazia
logo depois disso acontece a lua de mel
a lua de mel é aquele momento mágico
maravilhoso que você pensa agora ele vai
mudar
bom não vai mudar
o tapa vai ficar mais forte o xingamento
na próxima vez vai ser outro até que
chega o feminicídio
é muito difícil
estou aqui falando disso mas a gente
pensa que a violência doméstica é uma
coisa que está muito longe da gente mas
a realidade é que ela está acontecendo
nosso lado
foi aí que quando né
saí daquele relacionamento ela vou
explicar para vocês como eu saí desse
relacionamento
uma parte muito importante bom ele viu
que estava com depressão e falou dora é
você tem 30 dias para melhorar a
depressão
tá aí eu falei tá bom correr aqui tomava
remédio vou ficar boa pra você amor vai
ser o google no terceiro dia um dos meus
melhores amigos sofri uma violência
terrível e eu tive que ficar do lado
dele a partir do momento que o time
ficar do lado dele e eu não tinha mais a
única pessoa que estava próxima de mim
para me sustentar
ele terminou comigo que é o que o
psicólogo especialista em
relacionamentos abusivos minha equipe
não é o chama de o término também faz
parte da tortura
então espero o pior momento para
terminar bom eu estava com uma crise
depressiva que ia me matar eu não tinha
mais ninguém do meu lado eu achei que
fosse morrer
eu achei que fosse morrer eu entrei em
desespero comecei a passar mal tive
várias crises de ansiedade e aí a bom eu
falei vou ligar meu pai meu pai é médico
meu pai vai conseguir internar em alguns
pista em algum manicômio e eu vou ou não
o nome matar e vai ficar tudo bem vai
dar tudo certo bom meu pai chegou em
casa minha mãe também o meu ele já tinha
usado por questões religiosas
pra falar que eu era minha culpa a
culpada pela minha depressão antes mas
nesse dia ele sentou na minha frente na
frente do meu pai da minha mãe e tentou
me convencer e convencer a eles que eu
tinha acabado de ser possuída pelo
demônio
eudora figueiredo
uma mulher que até um tempo atrás
conheci de rafa completamente atéia com
país e mãe
completamente a deus e ele teve a cara
de santa lá e falar que eu tinha sido
possuída por um demônio e eu acreditei
esse é o nível de lavagem cerebral
eu não achava nem que deus existe e está
no começo do relacionamento no final eu
estava querendo que eu estava possuída
pelo demônio
bom eu cheguei há meses acreditar que eu
estava possuída pelo demônio e que eu
tinha acabado de perder o amor da minha
vida eu nunca sofri tanto na minha vida
eu achava que aquilo nunca ia passar é
mais graças à minha mãe e meus
familiares
eu consegui pedir ajuda que é o que mais
importa dentro da violência doméstica
pedir ajuda e receber ajuda então se
você sabe que tem alguém perto de você
está passando por algum desses
violências
você tem que dá ajuda você tem que
oferecer o que aquela pessoa só vê um
abusador para aquela pessoa te dá onde
soltar e segurar porque é um desespero
tão grande
eu achei que eu nunca esperava hoje eu
ainda tenho pesadelos ainda tem alguns
algumas consequências mas com o tempo e
depois do meu vídeo e de lançar minha
hashtag meu exlusivo e ver as mulheres
sabe me abraçando no meio ruim falando
do olha você me ajudou a reconhecer que
eu tive um relacionamento abusivo isso
me curou
aquilo me curou também falar naquele
momento me curou também tá falando aqui
me curou
eu achei que era tão óbvio que eu tava
tão louca que eu precisei ouvir de uma
ex namorada dele que ela tinha passado
exatamente pela mesma coisa que eu
passei quando ela tinha 15 anos com o
mesmo eis para poder ficar revoltada aí
eu fiquei revoltado eu falei não é
possível
aí eu percebi que eu realmente
relacionado com um abusador com o
manipulador
mas é por causa dessa menina que a
sicília bons
mas nove anos que estou aqui hoje e por
causa de todas as mulheres que
responderam o hashtag meu e abusivo e
que viram o vídeo que eu tô aqui pra
falar
nenhuma mulher - a gente não vai
agüentar
vocês têm que parar de nos matar é isso
basta eu não aguento mais
eu nem as outras mulheres muito menos as
mulheres negras periféricas que são
mortas todos os dias e não tem o
privilégio de estar aqui é um privilégio
que eu tô tendo pronto 150 mulheres
foram agredidas no brasil é isso
[Aplausos]
[Música]